we've already talked about the 14th
amendment in previous videos but just as
a reminder section 1 of the 14th
amendment says all persons born or
naturalized in the united states and
subject to the jurisdiction thereof are
citizens of the united states and of the
state wherein they reside
no state shall make or enforce any law
which shall abridge the privileges or
immunities of citizens of the united
states nor shall any state deprive any
person of life liberty or property
without the due process of law
nor deny to any person within its
jurisdiction the equal protection of the
laws and this last clause which i just
underlined the equal protection clause
has been cited many times not just in
social justice movements but in many
supreme court cases and what we're going
to do in this video is think about how
rulings by the supreme court represent
both continuity over time but also
change over time especially relative to
the protection of minority rights
one of the most significant test cases
of the 14th amendment happens almost 30
years after the amendment is ratified in
1896.
this is a situation where the state of
louisiana passes a law that
african-american people have to sit in a
separate rail car from white people and
so you have this gentleman here homer
plessy a resident of new orleans who
decides to test this law he sits in a
white only car and he is 1 8 african
american and he gets arrested this case
eventually goes to the united states
supreme court and they rule that the
louisiana law requiring separate cars is
not unconstitutional as long as the cars
are judged to be equal and this is where
that term separate but equal comes from
and this is viewed as a fairly infamous
ruling because it was the supreme court
reinforcing this idea of segregation
even after the 14th amendment had been
passed almost 30 years prior
now we go almost 60 years in the future
in order for segregation to be
challenged in a very significant way
then we get to the case of brown versus
board of education of topeka kansas in
in which the then supreme court rules
that no segregation is not okay separate
is inherently unequal and this right
over here is a picture of a desegregated
classroom around that time although this
is not in topeka kansas but it shows how
based on the passage of time based on
social norms based on a change in the
makeup of the supreme court how they can
make rulings that go one way or the
other plessy versus ferguson reaffirms
segregation it's perceived to curtail
minority rights while brown versus board
of education goes the other way once
again taking a look at the 14th
amendment
now if we fast forward to 1993 we have
another really interesting test case
shaw versus reno this is a situation
where after the 1990 census north
carolina takes a look at its
congressional districts and sends them
to review by the federal justice
department
the federal justice department decides
that the first pass that north carolina
took at the districting only had one
black majority congressional district
and they thought that there could be two
black majority congressional districts
so the state of north carolina
redistricted again and they created this
12th district here which you can see is
kind of a strange shape it's strung
along over 160 miles and this very thin
district
now this was taken to the supreme court
by citizens of north carolina saying
that this districting was a severe case
of gerrymandering which we've talked
about in other videos and it should be
deemed unconstitutional and the supreme
court actually did rule in 1993 that
redistricting purely on the basis of
race as was done in this situation even
though it was with the intent of having
more minority representation in congress
that this type of redistricting on the
basis of race was unconstitutional this
supreme court also cited the equal
protection clause and also cited the
14th amendment saying look once you
start
redistricting based on racial lines it
creates a type of racial separation
which is unconstitutional by the 14th
amendment
so these are really good cases to know
they show how the supreme court can rule
differently depending on what time
period we are in or depending on the
circumstance that oftentimes when we
think about equal protection we think
about protection of minority rights but
as we saw in the case of shaw versus
reno even when the intent of in this
case gerrymandering is to give more
minority representation it was deemed
unconstitutional because from the
supreme court's point of view violated
the 14th amendment